die welt deutschland berlin ist stolz
auf dich dafür dass du den bundesvision
song contest mit dem song wenn worte
meine sprache wären gewonnen hast die
frage die ich mir jetzt stellen nachdem
du schon fast alle von deinem leben
erreicht hast was wirst du jetzt als
nächstes tun was sind deine nächsten
pläne lieber maniac meint erstmal noch
vielen dank für deine unterstützung ohne
dich wäre das wahrscheinlich nichts
geworden das wahrscheinlich auch am
meisten anrufen von allen und was soll
ich jetzt sagen also die frage war was
sie als nächstes tun nachdem ich jetzt
ja alles ruhig alles in meinem leben
erreicht habe was zu erreichen war werde
ich jetzt meine biografie schreiben und
meine karriere dann beenden um dann
einfach sie in ein paar monaten wieder
zu starten und den großen comeback dann
würde dich dann einfach herzlich dazu
einladen sich dabei und zu unterstützen
und vielleicht müssen die werbetrommel
zu rühren
nur noch mal vielen dank
dafür dass du uns beim bundesvision
songcontest zum sieg geführt hat